we have eight weeks of boot camp ahead
of us batsman not working out at all
masking tape it is no friend to chilled
aluminum velcro color-coded efficient
environmentally friendly who's he
talking to
who is he dressed like a registered sex
offender can we focus for a moment
ladies please we need to talk about next
month's meal plan obviously everyone
hated the ceviche and I read the
suggestion box yeah it's on I'm gonna
stop you right there
I see through this week act you may have
fooled Colossus with this nice guy [ __ ]
but not me
don't be me Birkhoff NCW no no no no no
let her go let her go it's okay she has
a right to be skeptical look at me
I'm an easy target you know historically
mischief has been my mistress so I
understand but I'd like to think that
you guys have really rubbed off on me I
like to think that I've rubbed off
around you too
lot and for the first time in a long
while I like me I accept your apology I
never apologized I was talking to your
heart see you're not lost cause your
thoughts I'm proud you're everything I
knew you can be thank you Colossus just
trying to be the world's best x-man
sorry next person hmm something wrong
with the soap it's fine
I just filled it give it a few more
pumps there now excuse me it's dust
bunny season and I'm hunting wabbits
you